[Musique]
c'est un sujet qui va englober beaucoup
de problématiques puisqu'il ya à la fois
les acteurs les actrices de pornographie
il ya l'industrie de la pornographie il
ya des dangers de la pornographie mais
c'est surtout les violences que véhicule
la pornographie
pour nous la pornographie très
clairement depuis qu'on travaille sur la
question c'est de la prostitution au
film et c'est pour ça que ça rentre dans
l'objet social de notre association
c'est une position qu'on a prise après
avoir eu énormément de remontées de nos
équipes de terrain locale qui accompagne
plus de 1200 personnes en situation de
prostitution chaque année qui montre
bien que ce sont les mêmes personnes qui
sont victimes de prostitution et de
prostitution film et que au sein de la
pornographie il y à du proxénétisme à
grande échelle il ya des violences
sexuelles à grande échelle et que ce
sont donc deux systèmes indissociables
les vidéos qui sont le plus recherché
sur ces plateformes sont celles qui ont
par exemple hashtag mot-clé fantasme
familiale step father father donc c'est
vraiment des vidéos dans lequel le
scénario est un scénario incestueux où
les deux criminels et puis la dernière
chose que je voulais souligner qui est
extrêmement présent sur les plateformes
pornographiques c'est l'apologie de la
haine raciale
c'est d'une violence inouïe et tous les
travers de la société le racisme la
pédocriminalité
le l'inceste semble finalement autorisé
lorsqu'il s'agit de pornographie la
pornographie comme la prostitution que
sont des conséquences physiques et
psychologiques extrêmement grave sortir
de cette situation c'est très très
compliqué et il faut avoir un suivi
médical social le plus souvent on dit
souvent que ça va très vite
malheureusement vous de rentrée dans la
prostitution ou de faire un film porno
c'est très très difficile d'en sortir
c'est une industrie qui est criminel et
qui pourtant a pignon sur rue et qui
gagne énormément d'argent on parle
aujourd'hui de milliards de chiffre
d'affaires au niveau mondial de 25 % de
la bande passante d'internet donc il ya
plus de vidéos pornographiques qu'il y
en a sur youtube par exemple donc on est
vraiment sur un système complètement
massif et ils ont énormément de moyens
énormes et moins de moyens pour
embaucher en particulier des avocats des
lobbyistes
[Musique]
l'âge de premier visionnage de vidéos
porno c'est entre 12 et 14 ans c'est
très facile d'accès et c'est très
souvent la première introduction à la
sexualité que qu'ont les jeunes en
particulier les garçons quand on sait
aujourd'hui la plasticité du cerveau
c'est à dire à quel point les jeunes
peuvent être imprégné vraiment mais
façonnées au programme est conditionné
par tout ce qui les entoure la
pornographie joue un rôle énorme dans la
construction d'une sexualité qui du coup
est complètement en dehors de tout ce
qu'on pourrait imaginer comme une
sexualité saine respectueuse de soi de
l'autre qui est dans le dans la
découverte de soi qui est dans le
respect dans le désir mutuel et la
communication la loi du 2 juillet 2020 a
apporté grâce à l'amendement de marie
mercier déjà une première réponse pour
interdire l'accès au site pour les
mineurs on le voit cette réponse n'est
pas suffisante
80% des jeunes mineurs on est exposé à
des images pornographiques et regarde de
la pornographie il ya la loi et
l'application de la loi aujourd'hui les
trois heures obligatoires par niveau et
par an ne sont pas réalisés et ça
contribue aussi à ce que nos jeunes
n'est pas une vision de l'éducation
sexuelle comme elle devrait être c'est à
dire que si la seule image qu'ils ont ce
sont des rapports qu'ils ont vu sur des
films ou pornographiques eh bien ils ce
sont des rapports violents et ça c'est
pas acceptable